On September 22nd, just five days after the battle of Antietam,...
...the President issued his emancipation proclamation.
"If my name ever goes into history," Lincoln said...
..."it will be for this act."
The South was outraged.
Jefferson Davis called it, "the most execrable measure recorded in the history of guilty man."
At a Washington dinner, John Hay, the President's 23-year-old secretary...
...noted that everyone seemed to feel a new sort of exhilarating life.
The President's proclamation had freed them as well as the slaves.
"It was no longer a question of the Union, as it was that was to be reestablished.
It was the Union as it should be,...
...that is to say, 'washed clean from its original sin.'
We were no longer merely the soldiers of a political controversy,...
...we were now the missionaries of a great work of redemption;...
...the armed liberators of millions.
The war was ennobled.
The object was higher."
That December, Lincoln spoke to congress.
"The dogmas of the quiet past are inadequate to the stormy present.
As our case is new, so we must think anew and act anew.
We must disenthrall ourselves, and then we shall save our country.
Fellow citizens, we cannot escape history.
The fiery trials through which we pass will light us down, in honor or dishonor, to the latest generation.
We say we are for Union.
The world will not forget that we say this.
In giving freedom to the slave, we assure freedom to the free;...
...honorable alike in what we give and what we preserve.
We shall nobly save or meanly lose the last best hope of earth."